[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
[Aplausos]
u Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
en Colombia en lo que va de año se han
asesinado a 15 Defensores de derechos
humanos
1424 desde la firma de los acuerdos de
paz en 2016 unos acuerdos que en algunos
aspectos son difíciles de implementar
con muchos actores aunque no quieren y
que utilizan la violencia para seguir
controlando territorios que escapan al
estado Hoy hacen escala en París desde
el chocó Carmen berbel Martínez y desde
el cauca Héctor Andrés dicue Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros Muchas
gracias y bienvenidos Bienvenidos a
París bueno ambos han viajado hasta
Francia para participar recientemente en
el foro francoco colombiano vamos por la
paz en su segunda edición Y es que a
pesar de los acuerdos de paz con la
guerrilla de las FARC aún quedan muchos
grupos armados en Colombia y uno de los
blancos de esos grupos armados son
ustedes líderes locales indígenas
afrodescendientes que trabajan en las
comunidades por los derechos humanos y
territoriales según indepaz que es el
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz en 2023 ya sean asesinado a 15
líderes el último o uno de los últimos
es Marcos López representante por nariño
para el movimiento político hay coyoles
quería preguntar a ustedes si sufren
amenazas vamos a empezar con con Carmen
ustedes del municipio de un guía donde
es defensora de Derechos Humanos del
Consejo comunitario afrodescendiente y
forma parte del grupo mujeres vamos por
la paz recordemos en el chocó Es
peligroso su trabajo ha sufrido amenazas
siempre es peligroso desde que eres una
líder de tu Municipio del Consejo donde
perteneces hasta el momento no he sido
amenazado pero igual los actores armados
cada día cambian las técnicas de
amenazas antes Te mandaban avisos o
panfletos y ahorita ya las amenazas son
directamente que llegan a tu casa te
llevan y te Asesinan y Qué grupos son
que Qué grupos son en mi municipio hay
aproximadamente tres grupos armados los
el eln los autodefensas capitanistas de
Colombia y el clan del Golfo son tres
grupos que operan en el municipio
Héctor Andrés dicue usted es líder
indígena del pueblo NASA pertenece al
Cabildo indígena Páez de Corinto en el
norte del cauca el cauca que forma parte
de los cinco departamentos con más
víctimas en el 2022 según la defensoría
del pueblo que reportó en total 215
líderes asesinados en 2022 y en
departamento 26 usted ha sufrido también
amenazas de estos grupos armados Y de
qué forma Bueno un saludo a toda la
televidencia un saludo fraternal desde
el norte del departamento del cauca y el
pueblo NASA pues efectivamente en esta
zona Pues que lastimosamente la que más
engruesa el número de víctimas de
asesinato de líderes sociales y
ambientalistas ya por su importancia
geográfica y estratégica que tiene en el
conflicto armado y también en las rutas
del narcotráfico De esta zona en ese
ejercicio en el 2018 en unas acciones en
los cuales era autoridad de mi
territorio Pues iban acciones directas
de nosotros como pueblos originarios en
el marco de la autonomía nuestro
territorio hacia estas estructuras el
cual provoca una afectación directa ante
el movimiento la el espacio geográfico
que ellas ocupan en nuestro territorio y
Por ende pues
unas tensiones que me tocó una vez
finalizado mi periodo de autoridad salí
por un tiempo prudente del territorio
porque su vida estaba amenazada
exactamente
Carmen usted está trabajando en un
proyecto de recuperación de de zonas
deterioradas por la tala y la y la
agricultura y la ganadería extensiva
las amenazas de estos grupos tienen que
ver con eso o sea no quieren que
o sea la gente que vive en las zonas
puedan disfrutar tranquilamente de esos
es una digamos una lucha por el
territorio no
Sí exactamente sí estos grupos tienen
intereses tanto económicos como
políticos en el territorio
se realiza la ganadería extensiva donde
ellos tienen grandes extensiones de
tierras y cada día son degradadas
afectando nuestro territorio como
consejo Pero también es debido a varias
actividades antropológicas que se han
presentado en el municipio pero como lo
dijimos nosotros y a través de la
primera investigación que se creó de un
libro que hicimos de mujeres los grupos
armados utilizan el despojo de
territorio y también en nuestros cuerpos
para adueñarse de todo el municipio y la
zona Rurales
Héctor Andrés usted se dedica a la
defensa del medio ambiente también y
trabaja en defensa de la paz desde desde
la parte local No desde el ámbito local
desde hace mucho tiempo no qué tan
importante es ese trabajo local para
conseguir la paz
pues primero pues la paz Total no es la
ausencia solamente de la guerra como tú
lo acabas de decir
un proceso de paz se consolida y se
logra llegar no solamente haciendo
acciones en contra la guerra sino que
las comunidades tengan las garantías y
el acceso y el goce efectivo de su de su
territorio y medio entorno en ese
ejercicio de defensa de la vida y el
territorio pues se han hecho acciones a
lo largo de la historia en contra de la
explotación de lo que hoy la comunidad
internacional llama recursos naturales
que son en la extracción de petróleo y
minerales de nuestro territorio Entonces
al estar tanto organizativamente
comunitariamente en contra estas
acciones pues son acciones que van con
en contra de los intereses de estos
grupos que luego atentan contra la
seguridad de la comunidad y de la
autoridad en territorio
usted participó en las mingas de 2021
Héctor Andrés esas manifestaciones de
el entonces presidente Duque el
presidente actual Gustavo Petro les debe
parte de esa Victoria porque todo ese
movimiento indígena afrodescendiente O
mucho apoyo el cambio sienten que sus
políticas responden a lo que ustedes
piden y a sus expectativas
actualmente Pues todo el movimiento
social en Colombia y la sociedad civil
pues vemos
con muy buenos ojos y estamos
esperanzados en esas intenciones que
tiene el nuevo gobierno hoy con el
movimiento social Ya que en su
presentación del plan Nacional de
desarrollo recoge los mensajes de la
sociedad civil y de las organizaciones
sociales y étnicas que por muchos años
se había solicitado de momento Esperamos
que falta otro proceso que pase este
proyecto en el congreso de la República
tal cual como está y esperemos que se
haga efectivo Pues todo lo que está
escrito allí
Carmen cree que el gobierno debería ir
más rápido para garantizar la seguridad
y protección de las personas que viven
en su territorio usted nombraba por
ejemplo la defensa de derecho de las
mujeres y cómo esos grupos armados
utilizan a la mujer como arma de guerra
no la violación de los derechos de la
mujer Tendría que ir más rápido el
gobierno hay urgencia siempre ha habido
urgencia y ahorita tenemos grandes
expectativas con este nuevo gobierno
pero como lo hemos dicho durante la gira
sabemos que 20 años de guerra o más que
hemos vivido en Colombia no se van a
cambiar en en cuatro años de gobierno
pero sí tenemos la expectativas de que
cambian ya que para nosotras es una
urgencia y como mujeres más ya que
nuestros territorios no somos escuchadas
ni tenemos voz y menos por los grupos
armados que hacen presencia en nuestra
zona Así que la urgencia sí es mucha
pero sabemos que la van a ir lenta Ya
que en Colombia hacen presencia 64
grupos armados de los cuales solamente
han presentado interés sobre los
diálogos y en estos momentos solamente
hay cinco procesos adelantados donde el
más adelantado es con el eln y en
nuestro municipio hacen presencia tres
grupos y solamente uno de ellos El que
lleva el proceso más adelantado entonces
lo que estamos exigiendo es que ellos se
acuerdan también a los procesos pero de
no repetición también porque ya en el
municipio en el año 2006 hubo una
inmovilización de alias el Alemán Y qué
pasó tuvimos un respiro pero a los meses
otro grupo hizo presencia en el
territorio que es uno de los que está
ahorita que es el clan del golf Claro
porque en este proyecto megaproyecto de
paz Total no todos los grupos armados se
están acogiendo Y puede haber también
disidencias no como hubo con las como
como Víctor Andrés usted este mega
proyecto de paz total creo que es un
mensaje muy importante en términos de
consolidación de una paz al menos en
términos del conflicto armado que vive
el país históricamente queremos que como
bien lo menciona nuestra colega muchos
grupos que hoy en día están en la
clandestinidad pues vean esta salida
también como una oportunidad de volver a
la vida civil y que permita también a
los territorios salir de un estigma y de
una pobreza que se ha tenido a lo largo
de la historia por el accionar de estos
grupos ya que sabemos que atrás de ello
viene el tema de narcotráfico economías
de ilícitas y también el reclutamiento
de jóvenes para la guerra porque bueno
como dice la expresión el infierno está
lleno de buenas intenciones no una cosa
es hacer un plan desde un ministerio y
otra desde los territorios ver si eso
va hacia adelante o no
Qué necesidades imperiosas ven ustedes
que están ahí en zonas que a lo mejor ha
estado Ni llega no qué es lo que hay que
hacer Cuál es la urgencia primera en
este escenario pues lo que está pidiendo
las organizaciones sociales y étnicas en
el país uno es que el estado permita que
las comunidades tengan un rol mucho más
activo en este nuevo ejercicios que se
vienen realizando ya que pues han sido
nuestras comunidades las que viven día a
día alrededor de la guerra y como tú
mencionan la paz no es algo que se
planifica es de Bogotá desde un
ministerio sino que se planifica con el
actor principal que es la comunidad
justamente eso es lo que quieren
visibilizar con esta gira
en el foro en el que participaron aquí
en París vamos por la paz se habló del
papel de Francia y de la comunidad
internacional en este proceso de paz De
qué manera y Por qué es importante la
comunidad internacional
pues primero agradecer a la comunidad
internacional que
políticamente viene respaldando los
procesos de paz a nivel mundial y en
este caso específico en Colombia
un apoyo tanto político como también
económico yo creo que más allá de esos
apoyos yo creo que necesitamos que el
papel de la Unión Europea sea mucho más
activo en el territorio que no se limite
a solamente enviar un recurso sino que
haya todo un proceso de verificación
internacional y que las fuentes de
verificación no sea solo la
institucionalidad
colombiana sino que sea también a nivel
regional y local en el territorio con
las organizaciones pues muchísimas
gracias ya no nos queda más tiempo
Muchas gracias Carmen berbel Martínez y
Héctor Andrés dicue por haber venido
hasta nuestros estudios de París a
contarnos esa historia y esa lucha que
también es la de decenas de y cientos de
miles de colombianos Y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que también nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y France 24.com Hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]